The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: I like
just having you understand
that if you really want
to understand anything
about cities, you have
to immerse yourself
in the vast, vast
amount of material.
Now seriously, it's a joke.
[LAUGHTER]
The class on Tuesday referred
to a number of theories
which I didn't have
much time to expand on.
For those of you interested,
the reading on the sheet
I gave you is available
and worthwhile
looking at if you're at
all interested in expanding
beyond what we did on Tuesday.
This is supposed to
be an advanced class.
There's a prerequisite before
you can take this class.
And yet the field is such
that so much of this material
[INAUDIBLE] is the first
time you've encountered it.
So I work on the
basis of those of you
who want to pursue more
have available at least
some direction which to travel.
So the sheet is
really the direction
in which you might travel if
you want to explore anything
from [INAUDIBLE] text to
the work of other theorists.
OK, we switch gears
completely now.
We are on to the
serious material.
The first part of this class
is really just to warm you up,
to make you understand
something about urban history,
and to give you a
superficial grasp of what
theories about the form
of cities might mean.
The second part of this
glass deals more meticulously
with particular items in cities.
It starts off with a review
of industrialization.
Some historians claim that there
have been three momentous times
in human history--
something in the
neolithic period,
something in the post-religion
period of the Enlightenment,
and the Industrial Revolution.
Nothing in my mind contests
with the Industrial Revolution.
And in a sense, except
for your own education,
anything prior to the
period from 1750 onwards
is irrelevant.
I know it's a stupid thing
to say but I'll say it again.
From this class' point of
view, we start at 1750.
And today, we will
try to understand
a very complex
phenomenon, the phenomenon
[INAUDIBLE] which
increased almost
every aspect of human life,
particularly in England.
Why in England?
[HEAVY SIGH] Enough
theorists have tried
to understand why in England.
I referred you in the
reading to a book by--
a recent book by
a man called Clark
from the West Coast university,
University of California
in Davis, I think.
The book is called
A Farewell to Arms.
Did you find any interesting
ideas in that book?
Let me explain.
The Industrial
Revolution, as I was
confronted with it is
a high school student
and then at
university, was a set
of events by
people, individuals,
who transformed the built
world, from Telford in Newcastle
using steel to--
not Telford-- sorry, Stephenson
in Newcastle, learning how to--
teaching us how to
industrialize the railroad.
McAdam, from which we
learn how to pave roads.
From 1901, the first
British census,
we learned the value of
establishing a uniform system
for counting how many
people are in the nation.
The penny postage stamp--
the first stamp which
allowed communication by mail
in a systematic manner, and so
on and on and on and on and on
and on and on.
Nobody explains why it happened.
The theory is the
genius of human beings
all lumped together changed
the British landscape.
However, we can't be that naive.
We have to ask ourselves
deeper questions,
because these
changes are serious
and affected the world
in significant ways.
Clark's book argues
that, in a crude sense,
the world in England in 1200
was a world securing property,
free trade, all of the
basic economic conditions
which initiative
could take place.
In fact, [INAUDIBLE] a table
in the book, if you ever
read the book, which compares
1200 England with 2000 England
and shows the metaconditions
were the same.
What he argues of, which
is novel in this argument
about the Industrial
Revolution, that there
was a transmission, either
culturally or biogenetically,
from the wealthy, who
had bigger families
and who lived longer,
through a downward mobility
to the rest of the population.
And he cites a
number of conditions,
having examined the wills
of people from 1200 to 1800.
He derives a number
of conclusions--
that the world changed
for the people en masse.
Interest rates fell.
Murder rates declined.
Work hours increased.
Taste for violence declined.
Education spread to
the lower classes.
And savings increased.
In the handout today,
I gave you a review.
There have been many
reviews of this book--
some arguing with it,
some saying it's nonsense,
some saying it has some basis.
But Clark has not concluded
that it's biogenetic or cultural
or how the transmission
actually took place.
What is powerful about his
argument is that it's new.
It's fresh.
It's much more vigorous
than previous examples.
The taste for violence declined.
In 1851, boxing was
conditioned by weight.
In medieval boxing,
a big man seven
foot tall, boxed
somebody three foot tall.
And everybody laughed.
[LAUGHTER] I will cite you,
when we talk about Paris,
about the burning of cats in
public space to amuse people.
The tradition of beating up
animals through cockfighting,
bullfighting, and so
on declined and was
replaced by a rationalized
form of sport.
Manchester United was
formed as a club in 1878.
Today it's the wealthiest
sporting franchise
in the world.
Manchester, where Engels wrote
The Condition of the Working
Class in England, was hardly
the site, according to Engels,
for the emergence of a $100
billion sports franchise.
Taste for violence declined.
How do you explain how a
taste for violence can be--
this country, at the
moment, is engaged
in trying to deal with
what we could only
call a culture of violence,
in which violence seems
to be built into the
grain of the society
in a way which is
difficult to understand
and difficult to
do something about.
How do these changes take place?
And how aware were
those of us who
were preoccupied with
making decisions for people
about the cities they live in?
How do we understand
these cultural shifts?
I grew up as a modernist.
When I look at the work
I did as a student,
both in architecture and in
city planning, I'm embarrassed.
The culture in
which I worked was
very different from the
one in which you work now.
We can only understand--
and I'm not going
to deal extensively
with societal changes in
this period in England.
I'm only going to
deal with them when
they affect some notion about
the built form of places.
Otherwise, we'd be here, and
I'm incompetent to give you
a very good background in
19th century English history.
I'm just going to pick
on certain coincidences
and events.
For instance, Peterloo was
a gathering of protesters
in Liverpool, I
think it was, just
after the British won the
great battle against Napoleon
in Waterloo.
11 Englishmen were killed by
the police and the military.
152 years later, 13 Englishmen--
actually, Catholic Irish--
were killed by the British
police and military.
Over a period of 152 years of
this incredible transformation
of the society, the British
police and the military
didn't kill more
than 11 or 13 people.
It's a remarkable story.
And in it the origins
of Marxist thought
fits quite neatly, which I will
talk a bit about later when we
deal with Engels in Manchester.
Clark makes a big story
about the Malthusian trap.
Malthus wrote a book in 1798--
I forget the title.
I used to know the title.
Does anybody know the
title of Malthus' book?
AUDIENCE: The dismal
science [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN BEINART: No, no.
That's what it was
called by critics.
It's something about
the population.
Essentially, the Malthusian
trap, Clark argues,
is that, until the
Industrial Revolution,
the amount of food that would
be produced in a society
or in a city or in a village
was equal to the amount
of population that could be fed.
If there was an innovation
in the society's production,
incomes rose, but the
population stayed the same
because the food
supply wasn't enlarged.
Malthus in 1798m as I will
show you in the graph,
observed the most rapid
change in percentage
of population increase
that Britain had ever seen.
Manchester was increasing in
population by 10% per annum,
whereas European birth rates or
growth rates, population growth
rates, largely
because of disease
over the medieval period,
averaged about 0.6% or 1%.
Trevelyan, one of the great
British historians, I quote--
"The survival of many more
infants and the prolongation
of the average age of adults
marks off modern times
from the past.
And this change begins
in the 19th century."
Two phenomenon-- death
rate, people live longer,
and more children survive.
Put those two together, and
you have the fundamentals
of population growth.
In 1500, London's population
was between 40,000 and 60,000
people.
Paris was already had a
population of about 200,000.
So London was almost the
second great European city.
By 1851 or 1850, it was the
largest city in the world,
with an estimated population of
2 to 2 and 1/2 million people.
1851 is the signal date in
the 19th century for us.
What happened in 1851,
or around about 1850?
The most significant
building of the 19th century
was built in London,
the Crystal Palace.
Who is the chairman
of the committee?
And who built the
Crystal Palace?
AUDIENCE: It was Paxton, right?
JULIAN BEINART: Paxton was
chosen by James Cubitt.
Cubitt was the first
Industrial builder.
Instead of using medieval
feudal labor, journeymen,
on a daily basis, he
employed up to 1,000 people
on permanent salaries.
He believed, like many of
these progressive individuals,
that architects were
second rate and [INAUDIBLE]
in their behavior.
Cubitt, for instance,
advised the queen,
who wanted to develop a large
part of the Isle of Wight,
I think it was, if I'm correct.
I'm trying to remember.
He said, don't use architects.
They just waste your time.
Baron Haussmann in Paris
did exactly the same thing.
1850-- England was,
for the first time,
divided into 50% of the
population living in cities
and 50% living in rural area.
A trivial event, the invention
of camera processing,
the capacity to
photograph, to make
recordings of the built world--
the conquering of disease.
In 1854, a physician
in London decided
that cholera, which is the most
prevalent and most dangerous
of urban diseases, was not born
in the air but was water borne.
These are pieces we are
reading for next Tuesday, which
deals with this, and
followed by the biggest
piece of infrastructure
yet built in the world to--
imagine living in [INAUDIBLE].
Manchester in 1830,
the city couldn't
get people, municipal workers,
to go into their houses.
They had to open the windows
first, break the windows
to let in fresh air.
The British parliament had
to be stopped one summer
because the smell was so bad.
London rivers was so polluted,
all the garbage and sewage
and feces produced
by the English
in London, in a city of two
million people, went straight
into the river.
People made a living picking
up bones in the river.
This is the first chapter
of the book called The Ghost
Map, which deals with the
invention of the cholera
phenomenon--
not the invention
of the phenomenon,
the invention of the cure--
which details that
concept of life in London.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] started
to compare [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah, he did he
did a kind of Sherlock Holmes
thing--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART:
--taking random clues.
When somebody died, the
family would say, oh,
we drank something last night.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
he would track it.
JULIAN BEINART: And
he would track--
and he tracked it to the
central water fountain.
Remember that the British
had no sewage system.
So if you went to the toilet--
for a long time, the British--
at the Crystal
Palace, they invented,
or produced for the first
time, the toilet seat.
But the British
bought the toilet seat
but didn't understand that,
if you used the toilet seat,
something would happen to
the material you produced.
It's an extraordinary
phenomenon.
Let me just draw
these two graphs.
1700 to 1750, 1750 to 1800,
1800 to 1850, 1850 to 1900--
these are 50-year intervals--
1900 to 1950.
This is 100%, 50%, 100%--
1850, 50%, 33%.
1798-- Malthus' observations
are at the peak period
of the population increase.
So therefore, his conclusion
that the Malthusian trap
would still continue
was totally eviscerated
by the industrial process.
What explains this phenomenon,
the decrease in the rate
of population growth?
The graph shows two lines--
one ascending very rapidly,
one descending not quite as
rapidly, but rapidly.
This is explained by a theory
called demographic transition.
As you urbanize, you
have fewer children.
There are more costs involved
in producing and maintaining
a large family.
And typically,
populations once they
have achieved their maximum
through the migration of rural
to urban, as the population
now is largely urbanized--
or 50%, at least, is urbanized--
the population will drop.
1800, 1950, 1850, 1900--
1800, three quarters of the
country is agricultural.
1900, half is agricultural.
One quarter is agricultural,
and then a small addition
to make it about 70%--
80% urbanized.
These phenomena, in
different variations,
occur at the moment.
Population growth in Russia
projected for the next 50 years
is minus 25%.
Population growth for
Western Africa is plus 122%;
Middle Africa, 175%;
Japan, minus 13%;
as you move from Russia towards
the West, Central Europe,
Western Europe, minus 0.2%.
It used to be that
planners believe
that if you wish to
decrease population growth,
you should urbanize
people, that urbanization
was the fastest non-lethal
method of ensuring population
maintenance.
It's all a theoretical
posture prior
to cities being as large
as 20 million people
and also prior to the
growth of population
being limited now to people
who are in the absolute poverty
state.
So you have a combination of--
in a sense, you could argue
that, demographically,
when people have reached the
maximum point of urbanization,
and the family sizes
decrease, population can only
increase by virtue
of an increase
of that group of people,
which is largely possible
due to immigration.
So the more the economy is
advanced, the more likely
it is that immigration will
replace work and increase
population.
I don't know what the
percentage of immigration
is in America's
population growth,
but it certainly must account
for a significant amount,
because these projections
for the United States
are plus 33% over
the next 50 years.
Now, these are
guesses, but they're
better guesses than most people,
the guesses by the United
Nations, who employ a fairly
respectable group of people.
OK, why do people shift from
the rural areas of the country
to its urban areas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Hm?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] jobs.
[INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
But that presumes there's
no work where they are--
better work.
And better work implies
a number of things.
It implies what's being called
by demographers the life
lottery, that you
stand to higher
random chance of
producing good things
or being recognized than
you do in the country.
The second is the capacity of
the country to support you.
There are always two phenomenon.
Land reform has been one of
the more difficult aspects
of urban, rural change.
In South Africa, if I remember
the statistics correctly,
although 80% of the
people are Black,
of the population are Black,
or 70% to 80%, less than 20%
of the agricultural land
is owned by Black people.
You can see what happens,
what traumatic events happened
in Zimbabwe, when Mugabe
tries to manufacture
the removal of people from
the land in order to--
it happens to be white people.
South Africa is on the way to
increasing the amount of land
and operated by
its Black people.
But one of the
significant events--
and I think there's
a sheet which
covers this in your reading--
is the Enclosure Acts.
The Enclosure Acts
eliminated the possibility
of poor people,
rural populations,
having access to commons land.
At the time of the
census in 1086,
more than half the arable
land belonged to the villages.
Enclosure, by redefining
land as property--
the Enclosure Acts from the 15th
to the 19th century, enclosed
commons lands and
made it into property.
Between the 14th and 16th
century, thousands of residents
were evicted from their
holdings when many more
saw the common land that were
the basis of their independence
fenced off for sheep.
Raymond Williams' book
The Country and the City
examines this phenomenon.
In 1873, half the country was
owned by some 7,000 people
in a rural population
of around 10 million.
The capitalism of the
Manchester has been built
on an agrarian capitalism.
In the 18th century,
half the cultivated land
was owned by 5,000
families, nearly a quarter
by 400 families.
Now, you can argue
that modern farming
needed more land in
the subdivision of land
into common parcels.
But there's a rejoicing
about the profit of making--
converting common
land into property.
Philip Sidney, the
poet, writes about--
the term Arcadianism refers
to a Utopian condition
in English literature.
Arcadia is invented as some sort
of alternative world of wonder,
largely because of nature.
Philip Sidney invented
the term Arcadianism
in a part which was made as
a result of the enclosure
of the commons land.
So on the one hand, if
one simplifies the story,
one suggests that the
conditions of the poor
were exacerbated by the
removal of their rights to land
and was one of the
phenomenon which
caused them to move
involuntarily to cities.
Now, whether this is absolutely
true or not, I don't know.
Economic historians start
dividing themselves up
into capitalist-oriented
historians
and labor-oriented historians.
And you can take
your pick as to who.
But the notion
that land becomes--
that land is available to
the population is changed
to property has
severe implications
which Engels, in his writing
about Manchester, observes.
He says there are changes in
the social structure of families
once they move into
the factory system.
These are not
voluntary labor moves.
Engels claims that
the capitalists
keep people in an
insecure state by not
making them have available
alternatives to their jobs.
They don't have
security of jobs anyway.
And so therefore, they
abide by low wages.
Manchester, which I'll
deal with in some detail,
largely through the
writing of Engels,
became the most important
example of this manifestation,
the conjunction of rationalized
labor in factory production
and the deterioration
of social circumstances
beyond which the world had
not ever experienced before.
James Joyce wrote a
collection of essays
called The Dubliners in
which one of the essays
is called "The Dead,"
which was made into a film.
I don't know-- I
don't remember--
Joseph Cotten, I
think, was in the film.
I'm not sure.
The situation is such--
in the story,
there's a young man
who decides to leave Dublin.
Nobody can understand why
he wants to leave Dublin.
He says the only way to get
out of Dublin, as Dublin
is totally controlled
by religion
and by social
pressure, is to drink.
Irish drink because they can--
only where they can
liberate themselves
from the compulsion of
their circumstances.
This man is
considered to be dead,
but he's actually very
alive in making the decision
to move out of the society.
It took an Irishman
like Joyce to see the--
use this as ammunition.
I'm just jumping
all over the place.
Let's go on, because
there a number of things
I want to touch in more detail.
I gave you Leo
Huberman's subdivision
of the nature of manufacturing,
from the household or family
system--
it's there, is it?
I'm not sure what I
hand out every time.
It starts off with a
household or family system.
AUDIENCE: Mhm.
JULIAN BEINART: OK.
This is a construction of
the move from a system where
you produce in your own
house for your own use,
not for sale--
there's no work for
an outside market--
all the way to the Guild
system, where there's
a small stable outside market.
Workers own their own
materials and tools.
They sell their products,
not their labor.
Up to the early Middle
Ages, space in the house
was undifferentiated.
In Henry Fielding's
18th century novel
Tom Jones, which was
also made into a movie,
you see the behavior of a
family and the journeymen
who come and work and have
sex with the young women
in the attic.
There's a whole
bodily kind of scene.
People eat together.
Production and eating and
sex and families and children
are all maintained in the
same ensemble of interest.
The guild system
runs into trouble
in the 19th century with the
emergence of a factory system,
where production now is for
a fluctuating outside market,
carried out in the
employer's buildings.
Workers own neither
raw material nor tools,
and capital is needed.
The mortgage system, as I
will explain to you next week,
emanates from, at the
time of the transition,
from the fluctuating building
guild to the permanent building
society.
Those of you who live in
India and in South Africa
know that you borrow money,
still today, from the building
society, not from a bank.
Is this true in India?
OK.
I thought so.
What happened with the
temporary building--
the building guild is that,
as the middle class emerged
and became an enormous
clientele for housing,
they transformed their
identity from simply making
houses for themselves or for
the guild to becoming virtually
a bank for housing.
They invented the
mortgage system,
which according to
housing historians,
was as fundamental an
invention as the steam engine
in the 19th century England.
The genius of the
mortgage system
is that you pay off the interest
before you pay off the capital.
The availability of loans
in the United States
prior to later use of
the mortgage system
meant that you could borrow
money wither in a balloon
loan or a standard loan.
You borrow money of $100,000.
You go away for 20 years, and
you come back and say, here's
the $100,000.
By that time, the interest is
made it increased to $300,000,
and you haven't got the $200,000
you need to pay off your loan.
Some people argue
that this is one
of the fundamental reasons
for the Great Depression
in the United States in 1930s.
You have to also
understand, I think,
the transference,
or the invention,
of the idea of capital.
According to Engels, capital
is the unpaid labor of others.
In a simple experiment, those
of you who are architects
are not going to be able to
make much money in your life
if you use your own
skills by yourself.
As soon as you
employ others, you
pay them less than they deserve
or less than they produce,
and you skim off the profit.
That's capital.
I'll repeat Engels-- capital
is the unpaid labor of others.
So capital, in a sense, is a new
creation in the factory system
and identified by
Marx and Engels--
Marx more than Engels,
in Das Kapital.
So much for the change in labor.
I mentioned the
transformation of industry.
None of these economic
historians connect
the invention of mass-produced
iron or the various shuttles
and steam power they
used to produce cotton
or to manufacture
cotton, process cotton--
with science.
I don't know who's
written about the fact
that people were operating
on scientific principles,
new scientific principles,
introducing these.
Let's see.
I'd rather get onto--
by around 1825, while
England had only 2%
of the world's
population, the volume
of production in
English ironworks
was equal to that of all
the rest of the world.
Iron was always a
material resistant to--
copper and bronze, in human
tool development, preceded iron.
Iron was always difficult
to work with until somebody
thought about using
coal in relation to iron
and eventually producing steel.
Iron with a hopeless commodity.
Cast iron, pig iron wasn't
capable of much capacity
in the building industry.
Let's move on to another cycle.
One of the dictums the invention
of 19th century Marxism,
which took place largely
in England, with Engels
at age of 24 in
Manchester and Karl Marx
living it up in London,
supported partly
by Engels from Manchester--
both of whom were German--
Karl Marx a German Jew.
Friedrich Engels was younger but
the son of a merchant, cotton
merchant, in the Ruhr.
Well, after Marx was
banished to England,
he set about constructing
a philosophical structure
of what he thought would be--
what he thought was a
version of the Hegelian idea
that history is not
linear, but history
is composed of a dialectic in
which one state is confronted
by its opposition.
And then a synthesis
occurs, which
moves which moves
rationally towards freedom.
God alone knows that's a cross
explanation of Hegelianism.
What Marx didn't
have, although he
read The London Times every day
and studied the stock market,
didn't have the facts
of the case facts.
Marx was a bit of a snob.
He sent his kids, his daughters,
to private school in London.
He never earned a penny
himself, but was a man
who sat in the British Library.
I had a friend, an old man, who
worked in the British Library.
And one day, he went
to a retirement parity
for one of the guards.
And he asked this guard if he
remembered a man with a beard
who sat in the corner.
And he said, oh, yes, I
wonder what became of him.
[LAUGHTER]
Engels, at the age of 24, was--
both of them had been under
the influence of Hegel.
Hegel was first--
was a professor
in a rural university.
But then for a
short period of time
was given a chair at Berlin
because his philosophy was not
considered to be
dangerous to the regime
of the Prussian kings.
Engels provided them with
the data that they needed.
Marx talks about
facts, facts, facts.
Engels arrived in Manchester
because his family
had share in a cotton
produce manufacturing
operation in the city.
Engels' reaction to what he saw
in Manchester was multifold.
He liked the good life.
He drank Chateau Margaux.
He ate lobster salad.
He belonged to the
Manchester Royal Exchange.
He went foxhunting.
He accepted the life of a--
he liked expensive
women, on the one hand.
On the other hand,
he was curious
about the world in which
he suddenly found himself.
He had an association
with Elizabeth Burns,
an illiterate Irish woman
whom he walked around
and asked her
questions about why
the world was the way it was--
extraordinary for
a young man of 24
to produce probably
the most important book
of housing ever written.
He would ask her
question such as,
why does the main road not
run to the slum that we're in?
And she would say, because
they don't want to see us--
the whole idea of critical
distance, the phenomenon
of putting people and
pathways out of the way
of where other people
of another kind live.
You could take
the plan of a city
and demarcate its roads in
terms of critical distance.
Nobody goes through Mattapan
to get anywhere else in Boston
unless you live in
Mattapan itself.
No roads run through Roxbury.
Robert Moses created
the pathways of it
in the book on Moses.
The frontispiece-- there's
a map of Moses' road systems
evading the property
of the wealthy.
He would ask her why--
all kinds of questions.
I'm just drifting
off to some of them.
He writes about health.
50% of children
born in Manchester
died, either in
childbirth or as infant.
He says, why do
people live this way?
And the answers are we have
no other opportunities.
He says, why are you kept in
such a state of insecurity?
You don't have permanent jobs.
Why do you work at work
which alienates you?
You have to go to work at
6 o'clock in the morning.
The bell rings.
If you're late by
five minutes, your pay
is taken away, and
so on and so on.
Why are you supervised
in everything you do.
And then they say, well, that's
what the factory system is.
Why are you-- and so on.
Engels writes, I've never
seen such a social class,
seen a social class
so deeply demoralized
as the middle class.
They know no happiness
except quick profit.
Marxist philosophy
needed the establishment,
the factual
establishment of Engels'
writing about
Manchester in order
to deliver a philosophy,
which Engels had something
to do with, and propagating
it in Europe until he
died at the age of 75, close
to the end of the century.
Manchester was-- the
historical dialectic of Hegel
didn't specify what the final
condition of the dialectic
would be.
It simply said freedom.
There was no
instruction in Hegel
that it would end up in a state
devoted to egalitarianism.
Engels and Marx did this change.
They did something else.
They didn't consider
the British capable
of moving to the
justification to the--
they didn't consider
the British capable
of doing the changes that need
to be done to make Manchester
a relic, historical relic.
They were too slow.
There was a British
countermovement all the time.
The Chartist movement
was considered by Engels
to be not radical enough.
He and Marx decided after
1848 that revolution
was the only way to
transform society
according to the
Hegel philosophy,
that it needed to be abrupt.
And the 1917, 1918
revolution in Russia
was, in fact, the apotheosis
of this philosophy.
In England, as I said 20
minutes ago, it took time.
The Chartist movement was
a working class movement
which asked only for people--
males to vote,
not women to vote.
They were asked for minor
securities in jobs and so on.
The English version
of the Socialist Party
only started gaining political
strength as the years went on.
But by 1902, the English had a
Town and Country Planning Act.
And many of the anticipated
conditions of Manchester
had been alleviated in part.
There's some question,
again, as to how much or not.
Manchester was the site
of some other events.
Let me just-- a woman called
Ann Lee worked 14 hours a day
in a cotton mill as a child.
Her first three
children died in infamy.
The fourth was
stillborn, and, quote,
"as she lay in the
agony of delivery
for hours, screaming that
sexual intercourse was the cause
of all the world's evil."
What happened to Ann Lee?
Why's Ann Lee-- why do I
mention Ann Lee's name?
She left for New York in 1774.
What did she do?
Hm?
AUDIENCE: Shakers?
JULIAN BEINART: Yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, of course.
Sexual intercourse,
being infamy,
would lead to a resistant
community such as Shakers,
which only shook your hand.
That's the closest you came
to another body, at least
another body of
the opposite sex.
Yes, Ann Lee left London for
New York in '74 to lead the--
invent the Shakers movement.
In 1789, 15 years later, a young
Welshman who was 18 years old,
Robert Owen, borrowed 100
pounds and went into the cotton
business in Manchester.
He later went to New Lanark
in Scotland at the age of 28
from the USA.
He was the first socialist
leader in Great Britain
and the leader of the first
short-lived national trade
union--
also from Manchester.
I suppose, at any
point in human history,
there's a place which
is important enough
to change the world.
Manchester was that in 1830.
And Friedrich Engels fell
upon Manchester by accident.
It transformed him.
It transformed many
parts of the world.
And Manchester was the--
I'm just worried about time.
There's so many
pieces to this story.
The story of this
part of urbanization
can also be told as the story
of the encounter with disease.
I mean, 200 million people
died of the plague in Europe.
The Black Death which killed
a third of the population
of Europe enters
our story of London
when we deal with
London on Tuesday.
In 1666, one of the
people I will feature
dies of the plague, dies
intestate in these--
we'll tell that
story on Monday--
on Tuesday.
The correlation between
health and disease,
between health and the
improvement against disease,
is interesting.
When cholera threatened in 1832,
cities like New York, Boston,
New Haven, New York,
and Philadelphia
still had pigs roaming
the streets, in 1832.
Sewage flowed in open
ditches along major arteries.
Mud and ice plagued
unpaved streets.
And decaying garbage
could be found everywhere.
The rest are reports
from American towns
of similar conditions.
What is interesting is that
decline in epidemic diseases--
smallpox, whooping
cough, all of them--
follow this pattern.
The introduction of chemical
antibiotics in medicine
occurs when the disease
is virtually at its end.
All of this
prevention of disease
occurs through
environmental control.
The correlation between
income and health
is being proved by the
World Health Organization
over and over.
In 1899 to 1902, the British
fought a war in South Africa
called the Anglo-Boer War.
In evaluating men
for the British Army,
they found that only a
percentage of Englishmen
were capable of serving
in the military.
Such was the state, the
miserable state, of health.
But over time, the changes in
the environmental condition
of cities like Manchester,
although sporadic and due
to phenomena such as charity
or British experiments
with charitable
institutions, the invention
of social housing, the fact
that the state would actually
play a role in providing
housing was all a phenomenon
of the British creation.
But they didn't succeed
in many circumstances.
I will show you a slide which
showed the case of housing
in Scotland only a few years
hence, at least a few years
past, still in
abominable condition.
We move on to a set of
policies and changes
which were fundamental in making
this jump from the 19th century
emergence of the industrial
city to the condition
of emancipation that
I think everybody
has been wondering about since
the Great British achievement.
Let's look at some
of these pictures.
This is Pugin's
famous depiction--
the upper image is of 1440 and
the lower image is of 1840.
Look at what he's
conceives of in 1840.
The water system, the river,
is now enclosed by factories.
The determination
in the above slide
of tall religious
buildings is diminished.
Maybe one or two survive.
What is this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: But
it's got a particular--
AUDIENCE: Panopticon?
JULIAN BEINART: Panopticon, yes.
How he conceives of a
panopticon in England in 1840,
I don't know.
They were invented in
England by Bentham.
But it's strange that he would
place a panopticon so centrally
in the image of an
industrial city.
There's a church.
It's all a very
strange composition.
He identifies the
Catholic city of 1440
and the industrial city
of these steam pipe
towers as living
together some how.
Next.
Manchester in 1850-- sewage
running into a public waterway.
Next.
Manchester and Liverpool,
imports, exports,
railway mileage in Britain-- you
can take almost any graph 1840,
1845, 1850.
The railway system in England
predicted the invention
of the use of railways
in urban situations.
In 1876, the first
subway in London,
on the northeast of London, was
connected to a suburban system.
An enormously foresighted--
one of the reasons
London is at such a low
density compared to Paris
is the railway system.
Next.
The plan of a street in an
enclosure in Manchester,
tunneled 2 foot 10 inches wide.
It's 3 [INAUDIBLE] Glasgow,
an overcrowded dwelling still
in existence in 1948--
amongst the many critiques
of health in the British slum
are the drugging of
children, incest,
people sleeping in the same bed.
Here is a plan of an
overcrowded dwelling
still in existence in 1948--
built-in bed, man, wife,
child, and two girls;
single bed, three boys; mattress
on floor, girl on mattress.
Next.
Mumford's-- on the left--
Coketown-- the imposition
of an order of time
on people's lives, which was
different to the time structure
in rural life--
it was the kind of condition
of being enslaved by time.
The other critiques of
19th century industrial
was that it had absolutely
no respect for nature,
that it used land as
possibility of development
independent of what
its outcomes would
be on natural systems such as
water, sloping land, and so on.
Next.
A warning-- been invited
by the commissioner--
in the pest-house
of the metropolis,
the disgrace to the nation, the
main thoroughfares are still
without common sewers--
rates from time to--
and so on.
Unless something
be done speedily
to allay the growing
discontent of the people,
retributive justice in her
salutory vengeance will--
and so on and so on.
Here's cholera protesting
to Baron Haussmann
that the disease--
and so on and so on.
Next.
A commons environment--
land subdivided into strips
on the left, enclosed off the
common land, the same village.
Now these are objects or
sites for development.
Next.
And the pattern of
future industrialization
follows the pattern on the left.
The first of the British
reactions to bylaws
standardizing housing--
this is in the East London.
Next.
OK, on Tuesday, we will
deal with the marvelous
story of London's 19th
century development.